abone ol
o o
hey
hey hey
abone ol
[Müzik]
hu
gelmiş
[Müzik]
kurban ol
o o
abone ol
ben
[Müzik]
yoktum
çok
[Müzik]
kurban ol
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
bu Merhaba Hoş geldiniz
insan
içinden sayede anlayan var hem size
doğru
kız kardeşim var mı
[Müzik]
Selam bu gün sizlere etmeksizin yani
buradaki etkinliği başvurmasının
hayatında şekilde etkilediğini ve büyük
yolculuğun şifre karşılaştıklarını veya
etleri Anlatmaya çalışacağım
bizi çevresi olunca
konuşmalarında
hikayelerinde olacaksın kullanılan bir
kelimedir
geldiği kelimesinin kökeni nedir
bu
sayısal Benim derdim olacağız
kullanılabilir kelimesi
13.10 anlamına gelir
Peki Evet siz veya limitsiz olan
bu
[Müzik]
yapabileceği güzel şeyler Sonsuzluğa
olarak anlamak istiyorum ve güzel
şeylerimiz olur mu yani sınırı olsun
istemiyorum
müzikallerin dediğim veya düşünmediğini
şekilde ilişkilendirilebilir ve yeni var
hayatta taşır bu
Ne
oldu çevreyi tanımaya bizim için önemli
vurgulayan Evet siz kelimesini önemini
vurgulayan ve bazı yaşam olaylarını
tabağı olabilecek birkaç ifade ile
başlamak istiyorum
başlayabiliriz
yoktur ya
[Müzik]
en iyisidir oluyor önce setleri
sevgilisiz olması bir çocuğun üzerinde
kötü bir etki yaratabilir
Biz şimdi size az önce aktardığı bir
ifadeniz doğruluğunu öğrendi vurgulayan
ve hayatımızda büyük önem taşıyan birkaç
örnek vermek istedim
dokuz dokuz yaşından beri almaya gitti
Bakanlığı tarafından düzenlenen birçok
yarışmalara katılarak girişimin sözleri
aldım
2018 yılında Almanya'da düzenlendi
geçirdi izleyenler yani ondan Çevrim ile
yok mu cinsiyet adlı yarışmada hem de
aldım
Senin için ölürüm
bu
devam etti ama her zaman saçların birisi
olduğunu düşündüm ve başarılı vermeye
bileceğini ve başarının bütün ceviz
olduğunu düşünemedim başarı seviyenize
kadar büyük bir Gayret ve çalışmayla bir
edeceğim etseniz bile
Avrupa'da birçok ülkede konserler
vermeye başladı sana
geldiğinde memleket şarkısıyla yer aldı
ve Sayın hocam eserlerini içeren divane
161 Aydın yapıldığı
özellikle
birlikte hem hem de
O biraz yeterlilikle Evet Meclisi
Başkanlığı yapabileceğini ve bahsettiğim
gibi bir başarı büyüklüğünün hazır
olduğunu gösterdi
Şimdi bir şey devam etmek istiyorum Çok
farklı bir ifade eden sizlerle birlikte
paylaşmak istiyorum
Hayaller belirsizdir bir her iki sizde
Bence kafası içerisinde istediğiniz şeyi
Hayal edebiliriz hayatım Şimdi çok saçma
Absürt Ve mantık olsa bile
hatta kendi kendimize
diye istiyorum
[Müzik]
şu
anda çok keyif alıyorum
içinde
yapmak için çok önemli
İleride insana ve doğaya dair varmış
enerjisi ettiklerini düşündükleri
bir sanatçı olmak istiyorum ve
düşün
paylaşacağımız olabilmek istiyoruz
istiyoruz o
[Müzik]
bu
çalışma güzel
yorgunluklar insan
arkadaşlarına ulaşmak için birçok şeyi
giden aldatma orada kavga etti nedir bir
ondan bahsetmek istiyorum
oyuncuların hastalığı o
[Müzik]
bu kesildi oynamalıydı akşama falan önce
basılmıştır biletlerin satılması bunun
üstünde burada oynatması operanın büyük
ve önemli bir bölümü olacaktı
oynamalıydı
bana göre geçirdi ve operatörlerin İyi
güzel bir makyaj yapıyorum kızlar evi
post ile ele geçirdi paylaşabilirler
tamam mı
[Müzik]
Sen
bana atası özelliği uygulanabileceğini
hiçbir olmadığı
bir şekilde sınırsız olduğunu gösterdi
hakkında konuştum ama o
[Müzik]
bu sevince iyi özellikler düşünüyorum
Evet
şimdi
bir şey mesela nasıl desem
O bizim çok seviyorum müziğin sesini
olmaktan yaratmaktan çok büyük sevdi
alıyorum
yok
Yalnız bir şey olmaktan ve basit gibi
olmaktan öyle yapmaktan çok keyif
alıyorum bunun arkasında oluşan şöyle
veya çok da ilgili tekme diyebilirim
hiçbir zaman da farklı şekilde düşündüm
Şimdi
bunun içinden bizi çalıların içerisinde
yapmamak gerekir çok önemli bir maddi
Bir miktarı veya değeri şöyle yapılan
değil
benim için bir tutku ruhu çağırdı
hayatımın bir parçası ve her Sırrın içi
Bu yüzden önce
yaşamı daha da
ama bunun dışında
öğrenmeye sizlere be işte açık olan
şiddetin her türlüsüne nefret eden
barışa sevgiye saygıya önem veren bir
yaşam tarzına sahip olması
bu
[Müzik]
büyük güzel mi
İyi
o zaman nefret ve kıskançlık gibi
olumsuz duyguları da hiç zaman ortaya
çıkacağını zannetmiyorum
Onun dışında Evet gerçek anlamını
unuttuk çeşitli para kazanmak için veya
farklı takılırsan o zaman rft
şekilde büyüyebilir ve bu
şekilde
[Müzik]
gibi o
ne
olursa olsun ben seni hayatımda
müzikallerde her zaman güzel şehrimiz
olmasını istiyorum Size ücretsiz
güzelliklerle dolu bir hayat diliyorum
teşekkür ederim
Teşekkür ederim ya
[Alkış]